je suis très énervé pourquoi il ya un
chroniqueur ou une chroniqueuse ici qui
nous a caché une activité au raymond
encore mariama la lecture je vous le dis
non mais je vous dis c'est pas une
vendue je vous dis donc je vais passer
géo passe en revue chacun dans le tour
auquel vous allez me dire si vous n'avez
une activité en plus que vous ne m'avez
jamais déclaré pas vous je vous fais de
la radio par exemple comme m'avait
jamais déclarée et que vous souhaitez
déclaré maintenant avant que chanteuse
dorothée les professionnels n'ont alors
des tas de médailles masculins devaient
l'activité que vous ne connaissiez dit
la vérité mais n'avait quand j'ai mon
blog mais voilà j'ai ma chaîne youtube
et naïm dit la vérité bblog et ma chaîne
youtube
beinheim c'est tout jean-michel payer il
faut s'asseoir payer ou pas ou gratuites
vous savez quoi dites ce qui vous semble
bon de dire j'ai pile mon chien fait
quoi comme activité la chine of amiga
rigole pas je ne rigole pas du tout
envie de gré à gré même rien pour ça
[Rires]
moi ya rfm vous le savez et puis il ya
aussi animaux tv c'est bon je vous parle
de vrai travail fait une radio oui alors
peut-être sur les conseils des conseils
des gars je ne rigole pas du tout je
donne des conseils à sari vert fois des
sociétés
mais non les sociétés commencent à
cordes un accord accord j'ai travaillé
longtemps pour eux c'était obsar non non
non non non même alors oui les impôts
toi alors non
voilà c'est tout sophie koch
professionnel vous savez tout chef moi
je fais de la radio télé aussi éditions
presse écrite c'est tout beaucoup vous
êtes non coupable sophie koch le
coupable est ici parmi les six battu
mathieu delormeau à ba3 n'avoir jamais
caché que je suis animateur à succès
célèbre
un métier célèbre bientôt le cinéma tu
verras quand arrivera mais pour le reste
rien d'autre il fallait les fans de vous
mais je sais que c'est une activité
castaldi ou telle revient là j'ai
toujours confiance au retour est à
l'honneur non non non pas grand chose de
nouveau en ce moment là maintenant à
aujourd'hui
alors on facile ça y est je connais
aussi des géniteurs cinq relais et qui
pour vous le coin assaillent et moi je
sais qui c'est c'est benji magie c'est
l'un des deux coupables dès le deuxième
il arrivait qu'on lui et ne rigolez pas
parce que vous faites partie des coupes
droites et daf baysse zebina
les époux ou vider votre sac maintenant
valérie vraiment ah non moi oui c'est
bon oui oui coup de pression mois la
livraison et tpm n'est pas un petit peu
de mannequinat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
0e directement voiture 0-0 oui les
séries des deux coupables ce soir dans
tpm paix maintenant le coupable l'on
connaît dessus c'est déjà une
le deuxième coupable est un homme un
homme à la carrière déjà bien remplie
il est sur le plateau
vous allez chacun notre tour je vous en
ai déjà donné un ou plutôt une c'est
valérie benaïm qui est coupable de ne
pas m'avoir dit qu'elle avait d'autres
activités à côté touche pas à mon poste
à côté de ces beats à côté de ce que du
kif à côté de ces que de la télé à côté
d'eux c'est que du chômage
ben haïm musicant fois mais je vais vous
montrer j'ai les preuves
j'ai les preuves ici ménages à votre
avis qui est le deuxième coupable
beinheim je dirais
[Musique]
dépêchez mois gens me raymond benjamin
benjamin fouda ce n'est pas moi non mais
si c'est ça rien n'est fait mais ça non
du coup comme miss est désigné tout seul
lui rend hommage à ma dit nous il est
content mais c'est c'était embêtant ce
que c'est pas fait encore mais je savais
pas quand vous parlez attention à cela
non j'ai déjà fait non je t'ai rien il
va nous faire une montiel cf 1 pilotée
comme ingrédient ah oui le courant alors
pilote mais des mecs je vois que tu peux
lui expliquer il a dit que j'étais au
cou enfin non mais non mais moi j'étais
m'acheter une ceinture d'or paris césar
à il a reçu un coup de fil pour une
ceinture alors un pilote red bull un
pilote n'a pas la radio non c'est vrai
nom j'avais un pilote et demain on dit
que c'est pas parce que tu en fais mon
rythme non ça c'est sûr et on m'a parlé
du 10 12
9-12 9 12 rajoutez une heure au même
prix alors mais ça vous coule beikes
kamba l'elysée mais c'est pas facile
mais les gens s'intéressent à
casteljaloux rapide radio qui nous en a
pas parlé mais il en droit parce que
tant que c'est pas fait pression il peut
être super comment mais comment je le
sais les numéros et aux îles c'est oui
mais c'est à nous n'a quand même bernard
montiel aux années tout le monde savait
quand il ya quelqu'un qui arrive dans
une radio pour le neuf tous
c'est ça qui est d'insérer où les gens
nous appellent jean son cours elle nous
appeler jambes allongées n'ayant mis en
place un numéro à 6
et n'hésitez pas à continuer ses débuts
de mois en scène des enfants pour moi
chef jean-michel on est d'accord mais
c'est des enfants 3 de mozart si on
rajoute une touche la ville est au
courant c'est pas et le mozart du papa
d'un petit peu fort
foutez de ma gueule plus on m'a dit non
merci
oui mathieu pour moi chef celui qui ne
dit pas les choses c'est celui qui a
quelque chose à cacher voilà ce que j'ai
à dire
voilà pour moi pas pourquoi moi je le
ferai quelque chose j'appelle avant
alors je ne rentre pas dîné j'appelle
avant le dîner pas après un pour dire je
ne dirais pas là bas c'est où je sais
par exemple que vous n'êtes pas fait de
pilotes mais vous vous êtes fait un
pilote et sa part de l'homme au prévenu
ça fait partie de la sphère privée
on n'a pris personne ne m'appelle je
vous plaît j'aimerais donner la parole à
l'élégance au charme
s'il vous plaît allez allez gérer
c'est curieux quand même de faire un
pilote sans le dire et après c'est il a
le droit il a sonné moi ce qui m'étonne
le plus c'est que les gens vous appelle
pour dire que c'est un gars de chez toi
qui fais un pilote à l'heure actuelle et
on peut pas avoir la radio non puis moi
je l'est inquiète et annecy métaux ne
veut pas dire ce qui met en l'air ainsi
que j'ai proposé un but je vous dirais
comme je suis vous le savez et que
extrêmement honnête il trouve que
l'aurait dit il ya des gens dont il ya
des gens d'abord vous passez chez vous
qui était au courant j'ai prévenu
et voilà et ça n'est pas ça voilà
attentats prévus d'autres équipes parce
que des gens que j'ai fait les on vous
le dit
allez des gens haut placés de chez vous
ne vous le dit pas oui et c'est d'autres
gens qui viennent vous l'expliquer à
vous écouter parce que ça va se faire
j'en avais sonnerie benjamin qui m'a dit
j'ai fait pilotes mais j'ai lié à une
seule condition c'est que cyril soit au
courant que vous le prévenu ait baha
sachez en tout cas chez vous que il en
sera pas du dadou pas très rarement ou
pas il est aussi l'année des jo dadou
peut-être sera pas du tout il en sera
pas non à la pnl il aura pas perret page
pour voir et non pas ce sera pas bien il
risque de dire allez tout de suite le
nouveau lara fabian à trois ils allaient
de suite le nouveau michel sardou les
lacs du connemara
voilà je vous le dis comme ça vous avez
un petit peu voilà ouais bon il ya peu
logique
bref on a le deuxième coupable la
deuxième coupable je suis pas fier
d'elle ça se passe avec panache en ce
moment c'est mérité oui mais là il ça se
passe bien avec patachon
bah oui mesdames je vous ai trouvé
vous êtes sur un site mais non tender
c'est pire que ça un mature dating
contact des lézards mais c'est une vraie
marque a mis sa photo sur un site du
contact de femmes matures mature dating
c'est pour faire des gros cons haïti
quand on est mature
voilà mais là il n'est pas mature aller
nature mais franchement s est pas beau
ça un cri web et naïm médaille
maintenant ce n est pas vraiment
coupable mais voilà vous avez vraiment
vraiment mature
voilà et ben en tout cas bravo benjamin
j'espère qu'on aura vite la réponse est
que vous nous le dire et si on exclut
d'éviter je pense j'ai peut-être avant
la fin de la saison donc on se met
d'accord va très bien et puis ça
mettrait un petit peu de beurre dans les
épinards
c'est toujours important mais c'est vrai
on vous rappelle benjamin tension sera
loi et si vous avez besoin d'inviter
n'hésitez pas à inviter les personnes
ici autour de cette table
c'est gratuit et ça marche